vitale dove sei
sono qui in una specie di stanza anch'io
sono in una stanza è tutto molto strano
premere il pulsante sbagliato attenzione
i tranelli passaggio vietato anche io me
lo auguro qui c'è scritto qualcosa non
si passa e una faccia malefica anche
credo proprio che sla pc abbia rinchiuso
in un escape room
ti ricordi cosa è successo prima di
arrivare qua no non mi ricordo a chi
voleva trasformarti in una bambola
burattino come lui io sono riuscito a
fermarlo usando i poteri che lui mi ha
dato insomma è una lunga storia ori
trasformato in una bambola perché era
diventato un essere umano
wow non ricordo più nulla di tutto
questo è il problema è che lui deve
essersi arrabbiato sicuramente perché io
l'ho ritrasformato in una bambola e 15 è
rinchiuso in questa escape room ci ha
persino separato così non possiamo
collaborare
io qui vedo delle sue immagini con gli
occhi illuminati ci sta guardando e ora
ti descrivo la mia stanza e poi mi
descrivi tu la tua e vediamo qual è il
primo indovinello o enigma da risolvere
ok ok davanti a me c'è scritto non
premere il pulsante sbagliato esistono
due pulsanti uno blu e uno viola cioè
qualcosa del genere davanti io qui vedo
un grande pannello con scritto ti piace
dormire e ci sono due occhi illuminati e
ci sono
pulsanti qua uno e verde l'altro rosso
ok non premere niente ok premere nessun
pulsante invece qua sopra c'è scritto
attenzione ai tranelli
quindi vuol dire che sappia nascosto
pari tranelli e un biglietto qua sopra e
forse sì cosa c'è c'è una camera sta
spronando sì sicuramente sloppy ci sta
guardando poi qua dietro c'è un
proiettore è una scatolina rossa
prendiamo il primo indovinello tranello
o enigma c'è scritto vuoi rivedere
merlino premi che c'è un pallino quindi
immagino il pulsante viola
vuol dire che a merlino oppure una
trappola meglio non premere in nessun
pulsante ancora cerchiamo gli altri
biglietti o qualcos'altro ad esempio il
proiettore la scatolina che cosa serve
c'è qualcosa dentro cosa c'è e cosa vedi
ecco forse si apre così
non si apre deve essere uno dei suoi
indovinelli meglio passare a
qualcos'altro per ora dopo proverò ad
aprirla
vediamo se c'è qualcosa qua sopra
quasi una mascherina perché non so
perché la messa qui che cosa significa
poi forse qualcos'altro qua e un
biglietto con un anello a anche tu hai
un biglietto con ecco allora apriamo ii
entrambi
ok che cosa c'è scritto nel tuo
biglietto il mio biglietto c'è scritto
cibo illimitato tra amy e c'è un
pulsante verde non prenderlo non premere
niente ok cibo e io ho fame chissà da
molto tempo sto chiuso qua dentro
vitale non è il momento di mangiare
questo ok siamo chiusi in uno dei fronti
lei che dobbiamo concentrarci nello
scappare d'ape due stanze ok ok il
raffreddamento ragione anche se questo
pulsante mi sta continuando a tremare
non premere niente senza il mio permesso
vediamo cosa sia scritto il mio
biglietto
cosa c'è scritto descritto appuntamento
al cinema che cosa vuol dire folla dire
che sla chi vuole andare al cinema
sicuramente un indovinello o un tranello
l'unico elemento che può avere a che
fare con il cinema nella mia stanza e il
proiettore invece nella tua è vero
perché proiettano il film alcina sì
esatto quindi è questo devo girare la
manopola e proiettare qualcosa sì c'è
una parola
la pesca è fatto di legno non so se
funziona
vediamo
[Musica]
che io ho visto la proiezione era una
scena di un personaggio che ballava non
so che cosa voglia dire qualcosa nella
tua il libro c'è scritto ti piace a
dormire non cliccare niente qui ci sono
i due pulsanti rosso e verde no ok
e questo è il muro che ti dicevo dove
c'è scritto non si passa però proprio
qui vedo qualcosa che porta la prendo ho
paura che ho paura che sia una trappola
però che cos'è è una scatola nera prova
a prenderla piano piano ma da qui non si
sa si apre solo da un lato
ok prova a prenderla e vedo di che cosa
si tratta provo piano piano niente uno
scatolo ho paura che ci fosse un animale
vivo all'interno provo ad aprirla adesso
vediamo che cosa c'è cosa
è una specie di siluro ci sono delle
lettere sopra forse bisogna coprirlo
quante lettere sonia non riesco a capire
una specie di lucchetto con delle
lettere sopra sono sei lettere si ride
credo sia far rumore c'è qualcosa
all'interno
dobbiamo comporre una parola allora da
sei lettere ballare ballerino a una
lettera in più o sette lettere ballerino
è troppo lunga ma con troppi vediamo che
funzione speriamo che non fatti nessun
tranello
ok va bene allora provo con sla p ho
scritto sluckij ma non si apre non
funziona e quale potrebbe essere
dobbiamo pensare in dote al filmato nel
proiettore sono una persona che parlava
quindi sarà un attore
ok promo subito allora attore provo ad
aprile si si sta aprendo
ma non c'è niente qua dentro
e niente aspetta uscito qualcosa c'è una
chiave si corre la chiave per uscire
fuori di qui e io non vedo nessuna
serratura qui perché la porta è dalla
mia parte
o no la faccia passarti la chiave
puramente c'è quartiere altro enigma per
aprire la porta tra noi due e quindi
unire le sostanze io qui però non vedo
nient'altro tranne questi due pulsanti
quello verde che mi darà cibo illimitato
e questo rosso che non so che cosa serve
in realtà io qua o la porta d'uscita che
è un lucchetto qua quindi sicuramente la
chiave che hai trovato apre questo
lucchetto ma come facciamo a passarsela
il passaggio è chiuso quindi sicuramente
dobbiamo premere uno di questi pulsanti
per aprire il passaggio o gli strappi ha
scritto vuoi rivedere il merlino premi
il pulsante viola penso che sia una
trappola perché sa che è un mio punto
debole sono sicuro che uno di questi sia
quello dalla soluzione giusta
che cosa sta succedendo nel fumo di cibo
pancotto vitale che succede vitale non
hai premuto nessun pulsante vero
non mi senti che succede lì che cosa è
successo di tale deve aver premuto il
pulsante verde
devo sbrigarmi trovare una soluzione
adesso non so quanto tempo a là dentro
devo scegliere uno di questi due
pulsanti forse la soluzione scritta là
dentro e vorresti non aprire questa
scatolina ragazzi sono riusciti ad
aprirla
premi il pulsante blu il pulsante prova
la soluzione però che non sia un altro
tranello
la torta si sta momento quello la stanza
di vitale vitale ti piace dormire come
te volevo dire ti piace dormire lì tale
deve essere stato un fumo soporifero per
fortuna sera questa mascherina è come se
si volesse che io non mi addormentarsi
per continuare la challenger l'escape
room
non so come svegliare vitale adesso ma
devo sbrigarmi ecco la chiave
questa è la chiave per aprire la porta
una volta che apro il lucchetto della
porta renzo che sarò salva il potrò
uscire da me state un po meno che il
trap i nomi stia aspettando la formula
non riesco a portare vitale con me forse
prima dovrà sconfiggere strappi ma ho un
piano piano il lucchetto con la chiave
non funziona la chiave non funziona nel
tranello anche questo ora come fatto
uscire da cuochi vedete è chiusa dentro
la serratura
[Musica]
ci sono riuscita ci sono riuscito
ragazzi guardate bisogna farci fare la
parte di sopra la chiave non serviva a
niente
ora possiamo finalmente uscire
[Musica]
tutti ci caccino su perico previtali è
rimasto il tavolato tonino pate e vitale
da via decine di formati ti farai maria
paola personale ti sbagli di grosso
strappi carrù mario donna lo mammoni
carrasco
[Musica]
vai mai funzionato
vitale vitale che si svegliò si conficcò
floppy da ieri bravissimo arrivo è una
lunga attore ti spiegherò dopo
bellissimo arrivo
è una lunga storia ti spiego dopo e
infatti lui è proprio vero qui è
scappato no è impossibile farà solamente
svanito mora usciamo fuori di quanti
hanno subito da merlino 50 ventura è
finita bene ma bravo perfino chi l'ha
detto che bello vederti
[Musica]